good morning John last time you came to
us from the beautiful canals of Venice
Italy and so today I come to you from
the beautiful canals of Venice Florida
totally did not plan this John the
discussion of whether or not George
Washington is an evil person has spread
like wildfire across nerdfighteria
spawning many interesting and
intelligent discussions both in your
pants and in the comments I like the
concept of a what-if machine just so
that we can go back and see what
happened if we shelves someone in the
street or prevent a butterfly from
flapping its wings I like that there was
a nerdfighter named Devlin in your pants
so decided that we should actually work
up a list of criteria for what it takes
to get it evil baby orphanage and I like
that much of the discussion focused on
intent if we want to be good people then
kind of we are though I don't know that
that's precisely true and I start to get
a little bit screwed up here because I
start to realize that's not that
important that we figure out what makes
a bad person because I know that I'm not
a bad person and as nehi argyle socks
pointed out in the comic series black
did tell harry potter that you can't
separate the world into good people and
Death Eaters it's more complicated than
that and I know that I'm not a Death
Eater but I don't know that I'm not a
good person and I want to be a good
person so I want to know what the
criteria for being a good person oh
that's not something that we necessarily
intrinsically know John a couple years
ago I sat on this very dock right here
and I talked about how objectively bad
the practice of eating meat is and
that's still true the production of meat
still accounts for about the same amount
of greenhouse gases as the
transportation sector yes that includes
driving and if we took all of the edible
food that we feed to livestock in this
country and instead of feeding it to
livestock gave it to people no one in
the world would be hungry and yet I
still eat meat I know that it's bad but
I keep doing it because I like it I
recently read in good magazine I don't
know if you know in good magazine is but
it's a magazine I recently read that
they're challenging their readers to not
eat meat for the month of June and so I
think I'm gonna try to do that though
I'm not going to succeed entirely
because I'm with my in-laws right now
and I have to eat whatever they give me
because I have to be gracious also
really tasty but I'm not that likely to
get excited about that idea like I want
to eat meat and so not eating meat isn't
fun I do get excited about technological
solution like a bunch of scientists are
trying to figure out how to grow meat in
the laboratory much more efficiently and
without the need for the suffering of an
animal everyone I know everyone when I
tell them this idea they're like nah nah
well and I'm like for real you think
that there's something grosser than the
way we currently produce food because no
no there's nothing grosser than the way
we currently produce food also I find
this hilarious the United States just
revamped
the food pyramid into a plate in which
half of the plate is vegetables and
fruits which is fantastic and then the
other half the plate is protein and
grains I think that the protein is
hilarious because there's tons of
protein and vegetables and tons of
protein in grains so what is up with
that why is there a protein section at
all that would be because this whole
thing is being designed by the United
States Department of Agriculture not the
Department of Health and the agriculture
industry of America surprise surprise
thrives on meat eating so yeah it's a
little bit disturbing that the United
States Department of Agriculture's is
controlling the largest part of our
health equation obesity being the number
one health problem in America right now
so nerdfighters if you can find it in
your heart go a little bit vegetarian
this month see how it takes you maybe
you could just be a lunch eteri and
maybe just eat meat on the weekend try
it out knowing that denying yourself
this one indulgence actually is going to
make you a little bit better of a person
which will decrease your chances of
someone coming back in time and robbing
you from your cradle as a baby and
sending you to an evil baby orphanage
there's links in the description with
more information on all of this stuff
John I'll see you on Monday
you